hey how's it going everybody um I guess
I'll start the stream off by just saying
that we'll be giving away that t-shirt
towards the end and in order to get the
shirt you'll want to comment on the
episode of that Penndel engine so if you
haven't done that already there's still
time to go over there and comment and
then I'll pull all those via the YouTube
API and we can pull the winner that way
so in this live stream more than
anything is what I want to show you is
basically my video production process so
there's quite a few steps involved in it
and I think it's probably quite a bit
different than most other content
creators process but not a hundred
percent sure on that um let's see before
we get to that just add a couple things
that I wanted to go over see yeah just
making sure check in the chat make if
anything's off with the audio let me
know but it looks like we're good um see
here so yeah but all the stickers we
gave out on the live stream those went
out they went out this weekend it was a
federal holiday here on Monday so if
you're if you're in the United States
they should probably still get to you
this week and then if you're
international it kind of depends on the
postal service but they're yeah I
imagine you should have them probably
sometime next week would be my guess
let's see here and see other than that I
think I mentioned this last time but
when I'm working on a chat feature for
the ionic course so that would be an
extended module on that course so you'll
get another it'll probably be roughly 10
to 20 videos added with a whole nother
whole nother feature module with a bunch
of new stuff in it and then that's
that's underway I would say probably
about maybe hopefully sometime next week
but I can't can't really say for sure at
this point alright cool so yeah I'll
first just get into well there's a
couple good questions and I'll go ahead
and answer first before I forget first
one is from Henry and he's asking let's
see where do you find your inspiration
and for inspiration I generally find
most of it from our slack channel
because I'm constantly getting just a
steady flow of ideas from people and you
know people have different requirements
different problems that they run into
that really help me come up with ideas
so you know I very much value those
suggestions and try to put them into the
end product that you see on the channel
but aside from that like other things
happen in the web development community
that give me inspiration as well like
the edge browser just recently announced
support for web components so now what
broad you get time to start doing some
web component content let's see here so
interested in how does that production
versus post production look you'll kind
of see that once we get into the video
but yeah trying to go okay to your
coffee spaces or tabs generally coffee
in the morning and then tea tea in the
afternoon and then when I'm writing code
I usually use tabs because it's a little
bit faster now I just have my BS code
reformat it two spaces because spaces
are generally better for sharing code
between between people okay cool so I'm
gonna go a flame link video yeah flame
links a really cool product it's like a
it's kind of like if you had a content
full service like a content as a service
API but instead you host the database
through firebase which is a much more
efficient way to go and you can almost
you could actually build a content
management system yourself using
firebase you could use real time DB or
firestore and that's actually what I'm
doing myself for this upcoming fire ship
product so if you guys are interested I
can kind of show you how to build your
own content management system using
firebase from scratch which is and I
think a pretty cool project but we can
maybe talk about that one later
let's see so I'm gonna go ahead and
switch over to a screen share and then
we'll start looking at the actual video
stuff and okay so I just wanna make sure
that looks good on your end what I'm
actually looking at here is the very
first video that I ever produced and I
just I'm just kind of curious to look at
it because that's this is going about a
hundred and forty episodes in the past
back in April 2017 and you can see here
I'm not even using vsk at this point I
was still using the atom text editor
which I'd really liked from prior
development when it first came out it
was an awesome idea but BS codes like
just completely surpassed it and
features but the video really is kind of
not very good I mean it's two minutes
long and it's does some good things that
I like but overall it's you know not a
great video and so I think with video
production it really is something that
you start out not being very good at and
then you just learn small things along
the way and slowly make the you know the
video content that you're making better
with each video that you produce so
that's you know definitely an important
concept to keep in mind so starting with
the process I usually the first thing I
do is I come up with an idea and like I
said I get those ideas maybe from slack
or from just the web development
community community in general this is
so for everyone on the live stream
there's kind of a preview of the next
video that's coming out tomorrow and I
have all new graphics for the for the
video itself so you'll start seeing
these different I kind of cover styles
on the video so usually I you know start
thinking about how I want to present the
content so I might put together some
graphics that look like this and then
the primary amount of the work is
actually writing the code so I spend a
lot more time writing the actual code
that goes into a demo than I do and
producing the video and so we'll go
ahead and start there
and the one thing you'll notice in my
videos is that I have a different style
of showing code then you probably see on
any other channel I've never seen it
anywhere else but and instead of like
typing everything keystroke by keystroke
I do it in a faster way that's a little
more efficient for me to produce and a
little more efficient for me - voiceover
the code when I'm producing the video
and the way I do that's actually really
simple so like imagine I have this code
block here I can delete things just line
by line and reverse in the way that I
want to show it so I'll delete all this
stuff and then from that point
everything's copied to the clipboard so
I can just do you controlled see and
then have everything reappear on the
screen I don't like magic like it's a
really simple thing but a lot of people
have asked me how do I do this and it's
yeah it's really that simple
so what I do is like right now I'm on
Windows but I have a Linux machine
installed side by side on the system and
so I'll write all the code in Linux and
I'll record all the code screencast over
there and then I'll upload those to
Google Drive and the next step is to
import all that footage into Adobe
Premiere so what you're looking at here
is Adobe Premiere and this is kind of
like a just a quick preview of
tomorrow's video one thing I started
doing is I'm trying to like make the
intros a little more interesting instead
of just showing the same intro every
video I have a different background and
then embed the the intro video content
like somewhere in that image and so we
can actually split these layers apart
and you'll see that the intros right
there and then we have the actual image
with a mask over it so it's transparent
transparent on the screen and then you
can kind of layer things together to
make the video footage a little more
interesting
and I'm let's see here
so the overall process of making a video
in my case is after I have all the
footage shot I'm going to go in here and
do the voiceover
I pretty much sentence-by-sentence at
this point in the channel like I really
try to refine the voice-over content to
be pretty like consistent and clear
throughout the video and so you can see
here I've like sliced different pieces
of voice content and we're just kind of
going through the video in a linear way
um and oh and to give you another
preview of what's coming out tomorrow is
I have another shirt giveaway for that
video so and that's kind of an early
preview of what you'll see tomorrow um
let's see another thing that I think is
really important is having good audio so
you like definitely want to have really
solid audio for the intro and the outro
but one thing I learned is you probably
don't want the audio going through the
whole video because it is kind of
annoying for some people and I've
noticed when I listen to videos that
have constant audio it does get a little
annoying but you should definitely spend
a lot of time if you're making video
content you know figuring out the best
audio to use see I'm gonna take a break
and just check out the chat here really
quick to see if there's some questions I
can grab and let's see if iris any hope
of that will see any videos for flutter
there is definitely hope I don't have a
timeline for flutter yet but I've done
quite a bit of development with flutter
and would feel comfortable producing
videos at this point but I've just got a
little too much on my plate probably for
the next month but before I can really
focus on creating flutter content um see
my how to connect my sequel PHP with
angular 6 that's that's probably topic
you'll never see is my sequel PHP on
this channel and today come with the
graphs myself that's a good question
because um another thing with video
production is like this graphic you're
seen here on the intro is a highly
customized version of an event template
and so if you're looking for good
templates for your video content that
kind of the go-to place for pretty much
everybody is videohive
I actually have this pulled up right
here because you'll find all kinds of
like pre-built transitions and intros
and like logo stings and stuff like that
but you can kind of use as a starting
place for producing your video content
and a lot of these like the actual
creators are people working in Hollywood
that are doing these you know big-budget
films that didn't go and resell their
work to be reaped like reused in the
secondary market like this you know in a
lot of cases there's been thousands of
hours of effort from real video
professionals going into them so you
know to spend a hundred bucks on some
pre-built stuff is usually well worth
the investment let's see here and let's
see can you try something on web
scraping web scripting is a good topic
I've considered doing that with
puppeteer specifically puppeteers a
little bit slower for web scraping but a
nice benefit of it is that you can
scrape JavaScript sites so you can like
scrape content on an angular app by just
waiting for it to render all the content
which Mike do I use I used this really
crappy mic just an audio technica USB
mic i've been thinking about upgrading
for quite a while and i think i've
started to notice some like technical
issues with this mic so I'll probably be
upgrading that pretty soon for OK for a
screen capturing I use a really simple
program called simple screen recorder on
Linux I'm using Ubuntu version 18
version 18 point o4 C do you write a
script or do you just look over what
you've done and try to explain it so
when I first started the channel I wrote
a script and I would write all the
content in advance and try to just read
over that script it turns out that in my
opinion is not a very good way to do do
things so what I generally do is try to
write like an outline for an article and
make
make that blog post article first and
then do the voiceover in a linear way
like I was showing you an Adobe Premiere
based on how I think the video should
flow as I'm doing it so I don't I don't
know if you can hear the sound here but
so I'm not sure if you guys could hear
that sound in Premiere but I basically
go through the video step by step and
kind of go back and re-listen the things
and try to make it as refined as
possible and I don't think you can
really do that in a efficient way by
writing a script I mean especially I
mean it's definitely possible but you
need a lot of work a lot of extra work
that I think would just be an efficient
and the other program I use is Adobe
After Effects so After Effects is a
program that you would use more for
one-off one-off graphics so like say I
want to show a logo intro I have this
pixel storm animation and I can just
export this single scene and then bring
it into premiere for the you know entire
video process so this is a super useful
program as well these are kind of I'm
generally going back and forth between
the two of these depending on how many
animations I have in a given video and
let's see I'm trying to think of what
else I can show you here on the video
side of things that I don't know
hopefully that give you a general idea
of the overall process that I go through
let's see yeah just going back to the
comments here to see what I can grab out
of here and do I actually contribute to
angular
I don't really contribute to angular I
contribute to the firebase JavaScript
SDK and also angular fire too but I
think I've made like one commit to
angular and that's about it and at this
point I'd like I would like to
contribute to open source projects more
but I find that I just generally don't
have the time to like go in and you know
do bug fixes and stuff like that on on
these huge open source projects like you
know angular's its massive mono repo so
you have quite a bit of setup to even
like get started contributing
let's see some videos about react native
react native is something I might
consider covering in the future I think
it does offer some advantages over other
like hybrid app frameworks but right now
it's not a super high priority or
anything like that how do you prepare
yourself for a subject the best way to
prepare for a subject is to already have
built something roughly related to it
like in a lot of cases I've already
built certain features for clients and I
can draw from that experience because I
know like what problems are gonna run
into and what issues you're gonna find
and just try to really format that into
something that's useful that a developer
can use to get past these problems
quicker and did you buy Adobe yeah so I
pay like 50 bucks a month for access to
Adobe Creative Cloud
I'll get you access to pretty much
everything you need so if you're
producing a lot of videos that's you
know just a minor expense okay cool so
yeah I'm just going through the comments
here guys how do you get out of your
angular comfort zone I'm afraid to use
other frameworks that's a really good
question I think in development in
general you should usually try to be a
more general developer like you want to
be a JavaScript you know call yourself a
JavaScript developer rather than an
angular developer and you know it's good
to have some specialties but you
definitely want to be like have those
general skills under your belt so you
should know how things work with
JavaScript kind of at a more fundamental
level because once you know that it
becomes really easy to just jump from
angular to react to view because you
know what the underlying JavaScript is
doing rather than like just trying to
work with them
constraints of a framework and typically
also on that same note like if you're
looking for a job they're gonna
generally be asking you to code things
in vanilla JavaScript like algorithms
and basic programming stuff so if you're
you know on the job market you're gonna
want to be a you know well brushed up on
that type of code and what is the screen
resolution so screen resolution is I
record the videos in 1080p VP so HD but
then I export all the animations in 4k
so I have the videos are all videos are
all done in 4k that's the final export
and let's see education background so I
actually have a business degree in
finance I had originally thought I
wanted to be an accountant and then I
decided that programming was a lot more
fun and essentially just became a
self-taught programmer at that point got
a job doing like PHP my sequel stuff and
then did a lot of Ruby on Rails for a
number of years and now really focused
on mostly full stack JavaScript all
right so I'm gonna go ahead and I think
that's enough questions for now I think
now it's time we should go ahead and
give away the t-shirt and if I wasn't
able to get to your question leave me
like a comment or leave the question on
slack because a lot of these I could
answer in a future livestream but let's
go ahead and pull up our script and
we'll give away this free t-shirt let's
see here
this is the script we've looked at it
before it's taking this video ID pulling
all the comments from the YouTube API
and then it will pick a single winner
from that group alright so all I have to
do is click this button and then that
will give us our t-shirt winner so here
we go all right Samuel Camargo you were
index 31 out of 125 comments keep up the
good work excellent content thank you
for the comment really appreciate it
and congratulations on winning the
t-shirt so you get the shirt if you're
on slack send me a message on slack with
your address in sighs otherwise send me
a direct message via email or whatever
works for you all right so I'm gonna go
ahead and stop screen sharing here oh if
a person comments multiple times there
they're actually they are we check for
uniqueness so let me see if I can get to
this in the code yeah that's something
that I thought of if if multiple people
comment then they should only be only
have had the same chance to win as
everybody else so I use this unique bye
function do you check their channel ID
value and that will just make sure that
every person that comment it has to have
a unique Google account all right so I
guess I'm gonna go ahead and wrap up the
stream here like I said if you have more
questions I'll try to get to these next
time but this is fun and there's gonna
be another t-shirt giveaway on the next
video so make sure to check that out and
leave a comment we'll do the same thing
next week all right thanks a lot
everybody and I'll talk to you soon see
ya
you